foreign
so I'd love to talk a little bit about
cars today
so cars have always been an irrational
affair
if you think about it it makes no sense
whatsoever to take two tons of metal to
move a person from point A to point B
nevertheless we have 1.5 billion cars in
the world today
and they have a very dear place in many
of our hearts
so for some of us the car represents the
ultimate engine of Freedom like blow it
all off and drive away
and for others it is the coming of age
like maybe you had your first kiss in a
car I see you smile
or maybe the car even had a name
so if we look to China only 16 percent
of people say that a car does not
increase your status significantly
and in 2018 the world was watching when
in Saudi women took to the steering
wheel for the first time
musicians are writing songs about
microwaves of fitbits but Prince had his
song Little Red covert
and Rihanna had a great number one
Billboard Chart song with Shut Up and
Drive now when you look at car
commercials they typically look like
this super romantic basically they take
you in a very safe space fantastic
gorgeous landscape with your dear ones
around you
and you can basically Drive forever into
beautiful land
now of course we all know that this is
extremely glamorous but doesn't really
reflect reality when you do buy a car
today what this feels like usually is
like this right you stand in traffic you
look for parking space you breathe
recycled air clearly not glamorous the
other thing is if you put about 100 cars
from all kinds of Brands next to each
other I guess you will probably also
agree that they look more or less all
the same
individuality is clearly dead so now
next to this crisis of the brand and of
car industry there are three major
technology trends that are hitting the
industry massively the first one is well
known which is the shift from fossil
energy to clean energy that one is
actually well underway well understood
by 2028 we are expected pure battery
electric vehicles will be the most sold
type
but I'd like to focus more on the other
two
so one of them is the shift from
mechanical to software and what it does
is you don't actually have any more a
fixed product but it will continue to
evolve to learn to change it's a bit
like a touch screen instead of a
keyboard
the other one is you add AI on top and
it means that you will have the ability
to switch from Human operator to machine
operated and the robot takes over as the
driver
now of course car companies have also
understood these Trends and they are
working to incorporate some of the
capabilities into the cars
but I think we have a way longer way to
go and we will soon see the emergence of
what I call the software dream car
as opposed to the freedom dream car or
the other mechanical dream car that you
had in the past
so actually you may be surprised I'm
actually not a car guy so I don't have
petrol running in my veins or something
so I'm actually a software engineer and
I had the pleasure to work in many other
Industries before including telecoms
media phones TVs drones whatever comes
to your mind and all of them have
already gone through the disruption of
software and it made massive changes to
all of those Industries so I'm now very
proud that I can work with auto
companies who are just at the beginning
of this journey
now we have been approached my team and
myself just very recently by one of the
iconic car brands to Think Through
the future of that software dreamgirl
how does it look like
so we actually co-created something and
we reached out to a bunch of people
working with the auto engineers and the
designers for sure but then we also
looked at the professors in neuroscience
and biomechanics creative artists people
from science fiction all the way to
luxury Industries and we brought it all
together in a multi-disciplinary
perspective and I'd like to share some
of that today so I hope you are ready
for that off we go so let's start at the
center of the description this is really
the core functionality of the car and
obviously it will have an AI driver
driving you around now that AI driver
needs to be a factor of 10 better than
any human which means less than one
fatality per 1 billion miles traveled
this is a very hard problem and the
industry has been littered with failures
over the past 20 years to get this done
but we are very close
and when it does happen it will become
only one part of the functionality of
the vehicle
the other part of the vehicle is
actually going to be the in-car
experience all around you because it
will not be driven by the AI driver so
this is going to be shaped by augmented
reality and virtual reality now to show
a little bit how this could feel like
I'd like to just give a glimpse from a
movie that maybe many of you have seen
later on in 2049 fantastic movie I hope
you all loved it the ones who saw it now
there's one character in there he's the
bad guy so I love to talk about him it's
Wallace and he actually is vision
impaired so he can't see by himself but
he has a set of floating sensors in a
room and that gives him the ability to
see from multiple angles at the same
time
now it's a bit creepy because it's shown
with little bugs floating around so I
don't think that's how it's going to be
implemented in the software dream car
exactly but you get the idea that also
in a software dream car you will be able
to actually get like an overlay picture
to the normal reality that will have all
kinds of information and entertainment
around you and it will come to expect
that when you drive in the physical
world to a destination that you will
also want to be in the virtual world
during the same time and the vehicle
will be the thing the device that take
you to both places
now if I turn it up a little bit and I
look at the next layer I want to talk
about the performance and the quality
the software drill car will have the
basically a computing power that is
about 10 times faster than any other
device that you have and it better does
right because I guess we all got very
impatient when we push a button in our
cars and it like nothing happens for
five seconds
so you will get really Furious if it
takes more than a split second to switch
from virtual reality to real reality so
to say and what you really want is it
should feel more like a well
orchestrated dance between the human and
the Machine on Precision very fast
immediate and the same is true then
again for the AI driving if it feels
like a choppy right like you have if
you're in an Uber from the 2020s this is
not the experience you want to have you
want it to be smooth getting besides the
traffic and not like getting stuck all
the time
then let me go through the last layout
on top of this which is the one that I
find most exciting because this is
bringing together The Full Experience
and the comparison I'd like to make is a
bit like a photograph
a photograph can become a piece of art
and it does so because it makes you stop
start thinking search also for meaning
and you will have a similar impression
with the software dream car because it
will be able when you have downloaded
that nft photograph hopefully not of a
monkey or so but some other kind of nice
photograph and you want to put it on the
outside of the vehicle well you will
actually be able to do that no problem
when you are creative and you want to
change the functionality of the car but
you can program it download it and it
will do what you want to do so again you
are in control of both the interior and
the exterior experience of the vehicle
you will also have sensors in all the
surfaces so you can basically imagine
the car will be able to sense any
tensions in your muscles but also any
bumps in the roads and it can adjust to
both of them now what's actually
surprising maybe the technology is all
there it's not the barrier we have all
the lidars The Radars the cameras the
Holograms we have quantum computers we
even have brain computer interfaces and
they are operational for many years
people have chips implanted and it works
so why don't we see those softer dream
cars on the road
well it's a big step right if we look at
the automotive companies they obviously
have managed to get cars on the road for
more than 100 years but this step here
requires so much new technology
understanding data and the ability to
innovate fast that it is a huge step
forward for them
and you have about 15 million people
working directly in the industry
globally plus another 50 to 100 that are
in adjacent Industries and many of them
you will have to change retrain get into
the new world so it's a long way to go
and then you have the tech companies
well those guys they go wild they have
also made us already addicted to
smartphones and media and so on so I'm
sure they can make us addicted as well
to their car but they shy away from the
liabilities because at the end of the
day this is a life and death product
so you need to be really careful about
this
so as we think about the future I'm
totally convinced this will happen very
soon it's around the corner
now the question will be
is this now good or bad and that's a
fair challenge
now if we put it all together it's
actually complicated
because first of all that car will
mostly be available for the rich view
initially
also as I said before it will append the
lives of many people that are especially
in mechanical jobs you will have plenty
of new jobs coming along but they tend
to be in totally different places and
also in different skills
and also what's going to happen if you
make a product more attractive you will
actually have many more of those on the
street rather than fewer
so the good thing is again you take out
the human in the driving so it becomes a
little bit more controlled and safe
and then what about that Little Red
Corvette from Prince that we had a bit
earlier
well it's also going to be quite
different because the software dream car
will quite literally be able to read
your mind
which is kind of scary
but at the same time it also is really
good at predicting what you want to have
and your preferences which is kind of
nice
and also
the camera that you will have in the car
will actually be able to also detect
when that little child has been left in
the overheated vehicle
and the vehicle is able to basically
open the windows put on the air
condition call emergency services and
save lives
in their own way
now the other big thing I want to point
out is remember individuality which is
dead today
I think if we now look into the future
we will actually see that the software
dream car will enable you to really
Escape into a world that you can shape
on yourself both digitally and
physically
it is really up to you to make it your
personal experience again in the virtual
world and in the real world it's going
to be possible in a way that is way
further than anything that you have seen
in any recent past
so if we take this all together
I guess the question comes down to
are you guys technology optimists or
pessimists
and really what matters to me is over
the next 20 years when this software
dream car will come to the real world
it will be a bit like a white sheet of
paper it's not good or bad on itself but
it is the largest real life experiment
of AI and humans interacting on a daily
basis
so I would encourage all of you to
embrace it see the beauty but also shape
it and drive it in a way that it is good
for the wider Humanity
and I can only speak for myself to say
that I'm really excited about what the
future holds for us
but I got for all of you the question
will be when Rihanna will release a song
in 28
shut up and program your future self
thank you very much
[Applause]